oui
[Musique]
maman
bienvenue sur le plateau d'un tas dix
dates à dire en cas de match retour
entre marine le pen et emmanuel macron
l'année prochaine les électeurs de
gauche vont ils faire barrage au
rassemblement national c'est notre débat
de ce soir mais d'abord un droit de
réponse
rokhaya diallo ayant été nommément mises
en cause par le philosophe michel onfray
dans l'émission en direct de mercredi
dernier elle nous a demandé un droit de
réponse que nous lui avons bien entendu
accordé en kayak diallo vous dites que
michel onfray dit que vous avez dit ce
que vous avez dit vous ne l'avez jamais
dit droit de réponse alors oui j'ai été
très étonné d'entendre mon surgir au
milieu d'accusations très très violente
et très sexiste
quant au fait que certaines personnes
trouverait des excuses à certains
violeurs parce qu' il serait considéré
comme raciste et je cite les termes de
michel onfray et que ces viols seraient
en fait une espèce de revanche cause
postcoloniale et que je ferai partie des
personnes qui défendrait cette thèse
absolument sexistes et un raciste
puisque effectivement elle prêterait une
un régime d'exception au viol qui
seraient commis par des personnes selon
leur origine j'étais extrêmement
choquées de voir mon nom en fait
mobiliser à ce moment là pour moi il
s'agit pas simplement d'une joute sur un
plateau télévision mais véritablement
d'une mise en cause de mon honneur qui
matin et qui atteint mon entourage
sachant que je suis engagé dans le
combat féministe depuis quand même deux
décennies et que j'aie jamais prêt
donner des excuses en fait pour aucune
actes
aucun acte violent chamailleurs à lire
un extrait d'un texte que j'avais publié
après des viols dont il a été fait
mention
j'avais publié en février 2016 dans
libération et j'avais expliqué qu'en
fait un j'étais en contact avec des
féministes allemande et j'avais expliqué
car hashtag qui s'appelait house lost
qui signifie en allemand pas d' excuses
avaient été créés et ça signifiait d'une
certaine manière pas d'exception donc là
je cite le texte que j'avais écrit parce
que nous nous élevons de manière
systématique et absolue contre toutes
les violences quelles que soient leurs
auteurs
pas de circonstances atténuantes et
excuses ni de circonvolutions ni de oui
mais toutes les formes de sexisme sont
intolérables et doivent être punis je
regrette en fait que mon nom était
avancé avec une telle imprudence dans un
souci en fait de démonstration
quant au fait que certaines femmes
seraient des féministes à géométrie
variable et je regrette également devoir
particulièrement aujourd'hui puisque
nous sommes le 8 mars que finalement de
nombreuses personnes ne s'exprime jamais
contre le sexisme qui court en fait de
manière extrêmement endémique dans notre
société
sauf quand il s'agit d'accuser des
femmes particulièrement des femmes non
blanches d'être à l'origine d'une forme
de féminisme de féminisme à géométrie
variable pour répéter ce que j'ai dit à
l'instant alors il faut savoir juste
pour information que michel onfray m'a
fait contacté et m'a indiqué qu'il
présenterait des excuses publiques
je prends acte de cette prise de contact
de cet engagement
ça n'enlève rien aux dommages qui ont
été causés mais je pense que c'est
effectivement la moindre des choses que
de réparer une faute quand elle porte
des accusations aussi graves
merci rokhaya diallo dont acte puisque
et je vous fais toutes mes excuses de ne
pas avoir rectifié
mais on était en direct et et je ne
savais pas exactement ce que vous aviez
pu dire ou laisser entendre
à cette époque là voilà c'est fait merci
[Musique]
et maintenant notre débat du jour c'est
une une du quotidien libération qui a
déclenché l'ire des partisans du
président de la république ait laissé
entendre que si les électeurs de gauche
n'avait pas hésité à faire barrage à
l'extrême droite en 2002 et en 2017 cela
risquait d'être différent en 2022
il se pourrait bien qu'en cas de 2e tour
entre marine le pen et emmanuel macron
un certain nombre d'électeurs de gauche
n'aillent pas voter
laissant le champ libre à une victoire
de la candidature d'extrême droite le
vieux principe du fief du front
républicain anti le pen qui ne
souffraient jusque-là d'aucune exception
à gauche ou presque est il en voie de
disparition pour en débattre nous avons
invité christophe di pompéo député la
république en marche du nord membre de
la commission des affaires étrangères
en 2004 c'est sur une liste socialiste
que vous avez été élu conseiller
régional puis réélu vous avez quitté le
parti socialiste en 2016 pour rejoindre
le parti des manuels macron et en 2017
vous avez été élu dans le nord avec
l'étiquette lrm est ce que vous
comprenez que des électeurs de gauche
puisse refuser de voter
emmanuel macron l'année prochaine même
pour faire barrage à marine le pen
écouter parce que je comprends que je
comprends pas ce que j'ai et électeurs
de gauche élus de gauche pensé longtemps
et pour moi c'était une base la base
républicaine c'était pour se poser vos
extrême l'extrême droite en particulier
donc donc je ne comprends pas et je
pense que tous les électeurs n'iront pas
dans ce sens là une partie ira peut y
aller je pense que la majorité des
électeurs de gauche garderont leur bon
sens et leur sens républicain qui est
quand même une des valeurs une valeur
fondatrice je pense que l'idée de gauche
comment faire aude lancelin vous vous
êtes journaliste ex directrice adjointe
de la rédaction de marianne de 2011 à
2014 puis de l'ops de 2014 à 2016 puis
directrice du média de 2018 à 2019
vous dirigez depuis la webtv qg votre
dernier livre s'intitule la fièvre il
est paru aux éditions les liens qui
libèrent
est ce que vous comprenez vous que des
électeurs de gauche puissent voter pour
emmanuel macron pour faire barrage à
marine le pen
non effectivement c'est pour moi c'est
originellement incompréhensible donc
j'ai été plutôt agréablement surprise
par cette une de libération
je vois d'ailleurs que toute la
république en marche qui se sentaient
morveuse s'est mouché et c'est vrai
qu'après une séquence assez terrible
comme celle que nous avons vécue cet
hiver un loi sécurité globale loi sur le
séparatiste puis polémique sur l'islamo
gauchisme vos dents venant de la 2d mini
des deux ministres chargés de
l'université de l'éducation nationale
comment ne pourrait-il pas aujourd'hui
se poser la question
ces électeurs trompé par emmanuel macron
aurélien tâche et vous êtes député du
val d'oise et lui en 2017 sous
l'étiquette la république en marche vous
avez quitté le groupe en 2020 et rejoint
le groupe écologie démocratie et
solidarité avant de fonder le parti des
nouveaux démocrates
vous étiez membre du parti socialiste
avant de rejoindre lrm et vous avez
beaucoup critiqué les tendances
droitière du gouvernement et de
l'actuelle majorité alors est ce que
vous comprenez vous que des électeurs de
gauche puisse refuser d'aller voter bac
rond en 2022 qu'il compte qu'ils disent
qu'on ne les y reprendra plus déjà au
premier tour ça c'est évident que les
électeurs de gauche ne pourront plus
aller voter pour emmanuel macron en tout
cas ceux qui sont restés à gauche parce
que vous avez un certain nombre de gens
qui finalement se disent est de gauche
mais en fait avait abandonné c'est un
certain nombre vidéo depuis longtemps au
deuxième tour je vais vous dire que je
le regrette parce que j'aurai beaucoup
de choses à dire sur ce que fait la
majorité actuelle on va en parler et
mais je le comprends je comprends parce
qu'il ya beaucoup trop de gens
aujourd'hui qui d'une manière générale
de toute façon ne veulent plus aller
voter et n'iront plus voter parce que la
politique ne changent pas leur vie
depuis 30 ans la politique ne changent
pas leur vie et au bout d'un moment ils
ont envoyé ils ont envie d'envoyer un
signal qui est de toute façon pour nous
ça ne change absolument rien et si vous
regardez sur un certain nombre de sujets
effectivement aussi pourquoi certains
avaient
décidez de d'aller vers une macro alors
qu'il venait du parti socialiste sur
tous ces sujets de fond de société vous
venez de certains viennent d'être
évoqués à l'instant sur la question des
libertés sur la question de la place sur
l'astre de la société des citoyens dans
l'action publique etc
sur tous ces sujets là ils ont été là
aussi complètement trahi et déçu donc
voilà je non je n'en suis pas surpris et
maintenant il faut certainement se poser
les bonnes questions et c'est tout
refonder pablo pino vivien vous êtes
journaliste responsable éditorial du
magazine regards en ligne vous avez voté
jean luc mélenchon au premier tour en
2017 et emmanuel macron au deuxième
est ce que vous ferez pareil en 2022 bas
à ce stade je ne pense pas vous savez
moi ça fait j'écoute et aurélien a qui
disent eh oui ça fait plusieurs
décennies en fait que on essaye de faire
barrage
force est de constater que le barrage
marchait pas que la digue en fait elle
prend l'eau et que à chaque fois le
front national puis le rassemblement
national est l'extrême droite
elle gagne des parts de marché je vois
pas trop
enfin je comprends parfaitement en fait
que des électeurs de gauche à qui l'on
dit depuis plusieurs décennies
il faut que vous fassiez barrage au bout
d'un moment et juste envie de dire merde
à aux deux tours d'ailleurs n'est plus
du tout envie de répondre à l'injonction
qui leur est faite parce que c'est une
injonction pour leur fait souvent
d'ailleurs en amont des élections on l'a
dit attention là l'année prochaine dans
deux ans dans trois ans il va falloir
que vous vous mobilisiez pour battre
marine le pen est la seule alternative
que l'on vous donne ses ou bien un
néolibéralisme qui montrent bien agneaux
libéralisme sur les environnements ces
électeurs là c'est assez normal qu'ils
envoient être tout le monde
depuis 2010 cette eau - emmanuel macron
se posant meilleur rempart contre
l'extrême droite
pour la bonne et simple raison qu'il
serait le seul capable de la battre
est-ce que c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui
christophe di pompéo surtout c'est quand
j'entends pas de l'autre c'est que
enfin dans les différents intervenants
et sur le sujet c'est que à 14 15 mois
des élections
personne ne puisse imaginer qu'un parti
de gauche soit deuxième tour des
élections présidentielles et ça c'est un
vrai problème
la gauche dispose éducation moi j'ai
appartenu longtemps à gauche je me
considère en janvier tout comme étant un
homme de gauche
mais pourquoi aujourd'hui la gauche est
absolument incapable de se réformer et
de proposer une solution alternative à
ce que pour garder un candidat au
deuxième tour en mi temps de 15 20 ans
en arrière c'était inimaginable ne pas
avoir des candidats au deuxième tour
et là on a une atonie de la gauche qui
tout à fait qui est tout à fait
extraordinaire et avec un éclatement de
celle ci qui incapable de se ressembler
pour les pour les sujets les plus
importants
alors bis aujourd'hui parce que ça me
coachait t'éclater médias de mâcon reste
aujourd'hui le meilleur rempart contre
l'extrême droite
c'est vrai mais parce que la gauche
n'arrive pas à percer qu'elles
n'arrivent pas à s'entendre
les gens même un problème que la gauche
aujourd'hui en france moi je suis désolé
de dire mais une suffit de voir à
l'assemblée nationale la pauvreté des
débats à gauche qu'il existe aujourd'hui
relance l'a alors à la question pose
christophe di pompéo c'est vrai après
tout la question ne se poserait pas si
la gauche avait un ou une championne
capable de deux d'être deuxième tour de
l'élection présidentielle oui mais moi
je ne suis pas là pour être l'avocate de
la gauche qui a énormément de choses à
se reprocher dans cette affaire qui est
qui est absolument coresponsable avec
emmanuel macron de ce qui est en train
de se passer
il faut quand même savoir appeler la
provenance des manuels macron il pendant
la campagne électorale de 2010 est il se
réclamait un peu comme le député l'a
appelé comme arches qui vient de
s'exprimer
il se réclamait de la gauche de la
gauche réformiste de la gauche de michel
rocard et ne supportait pas qu'on dise
qu'il était ni de droite ni de gauche
évidemment c'était un c'est un mensonge
pour la bonne et simple raison que la
gauche sociale libérale qui était au
pouvoir avec françois hollande et
dompter il était alors ministre de
françois hollande n'a jamais était de
gauche au sens propre du terme à savoir
que l avait encore
un certain habillage sociétal mais le
masque et est rapidement tombée de même
sous françois hollande avec des mesures
comme la déchéance de nationalité avec
avec une politique extrêmement propre à
trauma et la gauche véritable à gauche
qui prône la justice sociale la gauche
qui serait capable de faire revenir les
classes populaires dans les changes
politique cette gauche là elle elle a
été littéralement pilonnée par le
système médiatique par les parties pelé
par le parti socialiste qui a d'ailleurs
liquider ces frondeurs pendant le
quinquennat de hollande donc il ne faut
pas s'étonner qu'au bout de quarante ans
de ce système pourri on n'est pas encore
effectivement eu un programme de gauche
populaire sur lequel se rassembler
aujourd'hui
aurélien tâche et c'est vrai que au 1er
tour en 2017
emmanuel macron mais le gros de ses
électeurs c'était quand même des
professeurs qui voter à gauche c'était
les électeurs du parti socialiste au
fond oui parce que il y avait
effectivement beaucoup de déception sur
le quinquennat précédent sur calque et
n'a finalement qui s'était un peu
endormie sur lui-même
ddd l'arrivée au pouvoir me le reproche
que j'ai que j'ai à faire à françois
hollande elle ses équipes de l'époque
c'est que très rapidement on les
trouvait dans une espèce de gestion de
l'état un peu moins injuste un peu moins
brutale que celle de nicolas sarkozy
mais que contrairement à nicolas sarkozy
qui lui quand il est arrivé au pouvoir
en 2007 avait une véritable ambition de
transformer la france dans le sens des
idées de son camp 1 rappelons nous la
droite décomplexée enfin sarkozy c'est
quand même le type qui arrive à vraiment
redonné de la fierté à la droite et qui
arrivent au pouvoir avec un programme
très offensif sur ses idées c'est pas du
tout ce qui se passe quand françois
hollande à are il est du coup comme
l'envi de transformation sociale n'est
pas assez puissant n'est pas assez a
rimé l'envi de véritablement bouger la
société et bien ça donne lieu à toutes
les dérives
et effectivement en fin de quinquennat
on a des choses insensées que la
déchéance de nationalité
on a une répression déloyale comme ricky
déjà ressemble à ce qu'on va connaître
par la suite mais moi je le dis
pourquoi à ce moment là je rejoins
emmanuel macron parce que sur ces
questions là sur ces questions de
rapport à la démocratie de rapport aux
citoyens de rapport aux libertés de
rapport à l'altérité
on entend une autre petite musique et
donc oui certains j'en fais partie
d'autres ça n'est pas le cas reprennent
espoir se disent bon voilà il ya
peut-être quelque chose qui peut bouger
il faut tenter
il faut tenter le coup sauf que ça n'est
absolument pas ce qu'on constate ensuite
est maintenant sur l'ensemble des sujets
que je viens d'évoquer on a même c'est
même encore pire parce que le fond de
culture politique qui avait à gauche et
sous françois hollande n'existant pas à
la république en marche c'est le souhait
de mener le maquereau et moi c'est
peut-être ça qui m'effraie le plus dans
la période actuelle c'est la
dépolitisation général de la société
opérée sous ce quinquennat l'assemblée
nationale elle même est très largement
dépolitisées la société tout tout tout
est absolument dépolitiser les anticorps
démocratique s'affaiblissent de plus en
plus et donc on y arrive on va droit
dans le mur on va on va à l'élection de
marine le pen on peut regretter
profondément c'est mon cas mais c'est
néanmoins ce qu'on est en train de voir
sous nos yeux est effectivement
malheureusement pour l'instant les
oppositions de gauche parce que les
autres moi personnellement ne
m'intéresse pas ne sont pas à la hauteur
des enjeux c'est vrai aussi ne sont pas
à la hauteur de l'enjeu
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
forcément un calcul cynique derrière
mais en tout cas il ya un manque de
courage il ya quelque chose qui n'est
pas à la hauteur de la situation pour se
rassembler pour proposer une alternative
et ça c'est vrai qu'il faut le dire
aussi parce que c'est tout aussi
déplorable sur la situation politique
française actuelle
un blog peyo vivien oui en fait quand
j'entends aurélien tâche et je me
demande en fait comment il va faire pour
aller voter emmanuel macron au second
tour en 2022 parce que en fait il dresse
un panorama un paysage de ce qui s'est
passé sous emmanuel macron qui me paraît
assez juste
et ce d'autant plus que la trahison a
l'air particulièrement douloureuse et
c'est ça aussi que parfois on a tendance
à oublier en fait quand
si d'air quand lorsqu'on parle des votes
des uns ou des autres
en fait n'en déplaise à c'était jacques
chirac dans les années dans les années
80 avait dit oui il faut voter avec son
intelligence et non pas avec ses tripes
mais il s'avère qu'en fait que beaucoup
de gens votent avec leurs tripes et moi
j'en fais partie mais beaucoup de
français en font partie beaucoup de
français votent avec leur fric c'est à
dire que lorsque la blessure en fait que
nous a infligées man et mâcon que ma
coiffe figé à la république elle est pas
uniquement théorique sur la question des
libertés sur la question des violences
policières ou un sur nous sur la
question sociale
elle est aussi en fait dans notre chair
et les gens en fait qui vont se
retrouver face aux deux bulletins au
bulletin emmanuel macron et au bulletin
marine le pen en 2022
cette blessure ils vont s'en souvenir en
fait elle va leur faire mal mais elle va
leur faire mal
j'ai presque envie de dire physiquement
en fait les français mais comme beaucoup
de gens en fait on a un rapport physique
aussi au vote
et ça on a tendance à l'oublier on a
tendance à français qu' il suffit de
prendre une balance en fait c'est ce que
vous ne verrez pas parfois certains
certains députés de la majorité qu'on
veut nous prendre grande balance on fait
la liste en fait celui mené de mâcon a
fait plutôt de bien et puis on fait la
liste de ce qu'il a fait pas bien et
cuir ont de comparer en gros
l'augmentation de 0 99 point du smic et
en face dit remboursement il ya eu
quelques épargné quelques marchés etc et
on pense que ça ce sont deux de fait de
quantité en fait qu'ils sont comparables
alors que pas du tout en fait c'est ça
aussi qu'il faut bien comprendre
monsieur le député de la république en
marche c'est que où notre vote le vote
des français
il se fait aussi avec ses tripes un
staff du bo
mais si on va te le fait que les tripes
mais pour voter il faut il faut proposer
des choses et font ses potes quand on
leur propose des choses qu'est ce que
vous proposez vous aujourd'hui à la
france a subi
ouais je vous entends fait pas faire de
propositions jamais jamais je vous
entends à l'assemblée nationale le
veinard violet en criant au scandale à
l'antisocial allons petits libertaires
pas vraiment mais il n'y a pas de
proposition il n'ya rien n'a rien et
alors on peut prendre tous les sujets on
peut prendre me séparer de la loi sur le
séparatisme pas parler aux enfants
on peut dire lui la loi sans séparatisme
c'est pas une bonne voie et c'est moi je
suis désolé moi je suis député de
maubeuge
abobo on a 35 % des populations qui
vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
on a un séparatisme qu'il y ait de plus
en plus prégnant dans la société
cette fois là elle nous permet
aujourd'hui de renvoyer des gamins à
l'école on peut dire que dans les
libertaires liberticide liberticide
voilà tout ça moi je pense que si la
gauche dont vous faites partie
la france a subi demain vous proposer
des choses peut-être que vous sortiez
une journée d'abord fonctionner proposés
il faut qu'il y ait un début de
commencement je vais dire quelque
propose aujourd'hui la lafa moi je dis
des choses qui m'ont marqué quand jean
luc mélenchon demande si on combat c'est
qu'on retire les drapeaux européens de
l'assemblée nationale c'est pas ça qui
veulent les français et les français
votent et chez nous on essaye on essaye
alors comme dit horner
on n'a peut-être pas campus parce que
justement en ayant des députés qui
viennent de toutes origines et qui n'ont
pas forcément le le parcours politique
tu disais avant avant moi je me suis
fait quand et des pouvoirs à 100 des
slas mais ça fait longtemps que je suis
élu et on avait les politiques qui
étaient là des professionnels qui
étaient là à vis là aujourd'hui on a une
population qui vient de tout côté alors
on n'a peut-être pas le corpus politique
là mais on fait des choses quand même
alors on peut les prendre certains bouts
je vais pas faire la libération que
voudrait que je fasse pablo mais moi je
pense qu'on a quand même eu des belles
choses et des choses social vrai qui
n'avait pas été fait depuis très
longtemps je veux pas parler de la santé
je vais pas parler de l'école l'école
c'est la plus belle chose qu'on ait fait
depuis le début du championnat mais
doubler les classes de gamins les mettre
à dos les uns pour qu'ils puissent
apprendre qu'ils puissent arriver en
sixième avec le niveau scolaire des
autres enfants
c'est la plus belle chose parce que le
seul moteur la seule source moi vous
dire je suis fils d'émigrés italiens
je suis dénigrée tanière et j'ai pu m'en
sortir aujourd'hui j'étais chercheur
avant de débuter
parce qu'il y avait l'école de la
république est elle à l'école de la
république est en déliquescence depuis
des années refaire ça remettrait les
deux mille classes pour que des cases de
cause douze fois que ces gamins puissent
arriver à un niveau normal et puisse
reprendre l'ascenseur social qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui
ça c'est des belles choses et c'est du
social et pour moi c'est une politique
de gauche
au delà cela
moi je crois que monsieur le député se
trompent s'ils pensent que la république
en marche échappera à son bilan à son
juste bilan ça a été certainement le
quinquennat le plus anti populaires de
la vème république
l'impopularité des manuels macron au
sein des classes populaires atteint
littéralement des records ces gens ont
été humiliés ils ont été paupérisés et
et je crois que que sur ce terrain là au
moins les choses sont claires de toute
façon ces classes populaires n'ont pas
voté pour macro et nous voterons
évidemment jamais pour lui tout ce qu'on
peut espérer c'est le surgissement d'un
candidat avec un programme fort
moi je pense que cela arrivera qui qui
sortira la république en marche
enfin de ce pouvoir pour ce qui est de
voter constamment un pistolet sur la
tempe de voter par chantage de voter
avec un repoussoir
en l'occurrence un parti fondé par un
ancien tortionnaire en algérie ça ne
pourra pas non plus je pense marchés
éternellement tout le monde sait que
c'est un système extrêmement malsain moi
personnellement je n'ai pas voté déjà en
2010 cette prime annuelle macron au
second tour et je n'en mets vraiment
conçu aucune culpabilité et même je
dirais que je m'en félicite chaque jour
depuis depuis que je voie ce qui a été
commis depuis 2010 est dans ce pays
il faudrait simplement énuméré toutes
les mesures qui ont été qui ont été
prises toutes les mesures de
brutalisation du pays qui ont été prises
et cela de la destruction du code du
travail jusqu'à la réforme des retraites
l'atteinte aux chômeurs actuels en
passant par toutes les atteintes aux
libertés en passant par la loi
anti-casseurs en passant par pas là par
la répression du mouvement des gilets
jaunes
je pense que cacau gouvernement pareille
ne peut pas décemment se présenter à
nouveau devant les électeurs de gauche
et les haies et leur soumettre
l'injonction leur donnaient l'injonction
de voter de voter pour lui je pense même
que emmanuel macron s'il était
conséquent ne devrait pas se représenter
à la présidence de la république de même
que son mentor hollande
aude lancelin vous avez accusé
jean-marie le pen d'avoir torture en
algérie je vous rappelle que il est
toujours nié et que jamais on a pu
prouver qu'il avait torture en algérie
donc j'ai eu un droit de réponse dans
cette émission j'aimerais autant ne pas
en avoir un autre dans la prochaine
voilà c'est dit
on est attaché vouliez elle ajouté
quelque chose oui non pour j'entendais
pablo tout à l'heure qui se demandaient
comment j'ai appris ce deuxième tour
après ce que j'ai dit évidemment que
d'abord je ne souhaite pas que ça arrive
et donc moi je continue de me dire quand
même qu'il doit y avoir un chemin pour
éviter ce deuxième tour emmanuel macron
face à marine le pen et c'est ça qui va
m'amener pendant les et les mois qui
viennent parce que je crois que
évidemment si ce deuxième tour arrive
quel que soit ce que je ferais ou pas ça
va pas cela importe peu finalement
marine le pen emportera l'élection parce
qu'effectivement il ya trop de gens qui
aujourd'hui ne se déplaceront pas pour
de bonnes ou de mauvaises raisons pour
penser ce qu'on veut c'est un faire
encore une fois ce qui s'est passé sous
ce quinquennat ou ce qui ne s'est pas
passé aussi parce que beaucoup avaient
un dernier espoir on se disait on a on a
cru en un an la gauche alors peut-être
qu'on peut peut-être certains
considérons ici que le ps effectivement
été pas la gauche ni celui de françois
hollande ni même celui d'avant mais en
tout cas beaucoup de gens on avait cette
vision là et avait été extrêmement déçus
notamment les catégories populaires dont
on parle beaucoup ce soir finalement
emmanuel macron arrive avec son idée de
révolution démocratique
rien ne change et puis au delà de ça je
le dis encore une fois il ya un certain
nombre de failles à une approche de la
politique alors je sais pas si c est que
les tripes ou pas mais en tout cas c'est
là où je rejoins ce que ce que faisait
pas beau c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui n'est pas que deux lors des
politiques publiques en fait et qui
n'est pas que de l'ordre comptable en
fait ça peut pas être que des des
chiffres en face de oui on regarde et on
augmenter un petit peu tel budget ou
autre quand vous avez effectivement sur
tout un tas de sujets quelque chose qui
paraît déshumanisé je donne un exemple
la politique des réfugiés mois sur
laquelle j'ai beaucoup travaillé
alors on va accueillir ceux qui auraient
le droit à l'asile et puis chassé les
autres et donc comme on part du principe
que
bon peut-être une partie des personnes
ou une large part des personnes si on
suit les règles du droit d'asile qui
sont très compliquées n'ayant pas le
droit en france par exemple dans celles
qui sont présentes à calais ou ailleurs
on peut tout faire pour les empêcher de
s'installer on peut bien venir la serre
et leur tante on peut les déplacer
heure après heure on peut enlever avec
des grues leurs habitations de fortune
on peut même laisser une femme qui perd
les eaux faire une fausse couche devant
devant des policiers qui n'appelle pas
l'hôpital c'est ça que les français vont
rejeter ces cette déshumanisation là en
réalité au delà même du bilan il ya une
dépolitisation il ya une manière
d'aborder l'état la politique la
démocratie par cette majorité à laquelle
j'ai appartenu et que j'ai quitté kiki
qui paraît wii qui paraît totalement
déshumanisé et au bout d'un moment c'est
ça que qui fait que les gens ne se
lèveront pas mis au premier et le
deuxième tour pour aller voter au delà
même de savoir si dans tel ou tel
domaine
il ya eu tel ou tel résultat et ça c'est
cette espèce de de technocratie au
pouvoir de dépolitisation de la société
qui est autoritarisme doux qui ne dit
pas son nom que les gens vont rejeter
effectivement alors moi si je devais
quand même faire un choix à titre
personnel mais c'est dramatique comme
choix bien sûr que c'est moins moi mon
pays envoie donc quelques que le que
l'autoritarisme fort et est ouvertement
racistes et nationalistes de marine le
pen mais néanmoins ça n'est pas
acceptable de s'en remettre à une telle
alternative donc il faut absolument
effectivement se mobiliser pour que ce
deuxième tour ne soit pas celui là et
sinon malheureusement je crains que nous
irons vers le pire parce qu' une
majorité de gens pour les raisons que
j'ai évoquées n'iront pas de toute façon
voter au deuxième tour si c'est ça qu'on
leur propose on fait une pause
on prend ce débat juste après
[Musique]
freiner le réchauffement climatique tout
en stimulant la croissance voici a
grossièrement la finalité de ce que l'on
appelle communément la relance verte
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire comme
relance verte quand vous avez une
économie qui est entièrement mondialisée
c'est des mots c'est de la com j'ai non
seulement indispensable mais c'est une
condition survie à moyen long terme de
l'espèce humaine
le premier grand sujet c'est de réduire
l'usagé du pétrole et du gaz comme aux
gestes quotidiens
oui il faudrait faire quelque chose mais
on ne s'en donne absolument pas les
moyens et on n'a pas du tout envie même
bill gates de dire son dernier bouquin
aucune travail terme est possible si on
réduit pas notre consommation d'énergie
monsieur le maire nous explique qu'on va
rembourser toutes leurs bêtises avec une
croissance exceptionnellement forte je
voudrais qu'on m'explique comment on va
arriver à baisser la consommation
d'énergie et faire 6% de croissance de
l'autre côté ça va être compliqué
[Musique]
l'actualité hervé morin c'est évidemment
la crise sanitaire ce que je défends
c'est bien sûr la territorialisation de
la gestion de l'épidémie on voit bien qu
un système centralisé bureaucratique tel
que celui ci a produit toute une série
de dysfonctionnements pas masquer dans
un premier temps pas de test dans un
second temps puis désormais une
insuffisance de vaccins
on a senti que vous étiez nerveux et
agacé à l'encontre de la politique de
l'exécutif
quant à au déploiement de la vaccination
et je constate c'est que l'on est le 36e
pays en matière de vaccination
bon ça prouve à quel point on a un
système efficace
en normandie on aura deux usines qui
bientôt produiront des vaccins qui pour
l'un va être bientôt autorisés sur le
marché compte tenu de la faiblesse de la
vaccination je vois pas comment dans
quatre à six semaines
on pourrait se retrouver libéré
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat avec christophe di
pompéo qui est député du nord la
république en marche avec aude lancelin
cayla directrice de la webtv qg avec
orianne lien tâche et qui est député du
val d'oise mais qui a quitté le groupe
la république en marche et avec pablo
pino vivien qui est responsable
éditorial du magazine regards en ligne
vous l'avez dit on ne cesse de nous le
répéter ces derniers temps je marine le
pen seraient aux portes du pouvoir
et on nous dit ça à chaque fois marine
le pen est aux portes du pouvoir
marine le pen risque d'être réélu les
médias ont menti en 2017 quand il disait
que marine le pen risquait d'être élu
quel risque est gagné c'est faux à aucun
moment on a pensé on a pu penser que
marine le pen allait être élu et là on
recommence
en ce moment
alors est ce qu'aujourd'hui marine le
pen a davantage de chances de gagner
ou est-ce que c'est simplement me
emmanuel macron qui a moins de chance
lui de gagner
aude lancelin non moi je pense que je ne
pense pas que marine le pen soit aux
portes du pouvoir
je pense qu'on est encore en train
d'organiser une grande peur qui
finalement profite au pouvoir je pense
qu'il y aura une pression maximale
d'abord si jamais si jamie marine le pen
était été dans cette position et et que
par ailleurs les gens qui ont voté pour
le banyan maquereau en 2017 sont
finalement prêt je le pense
structurellement à recommencer parce que
il ya quelque chose là de profonds en
fait de dans la gauche dans cette dans
cette attitude
d'abord la gauche adorent se raconter
des comédies de résistance 2 et plus les
manifestations souvenez vous du 1er mai
2002 sont massives sont sont
conformistes plus le grand-père de la
résistance et chanter fort donc ça je
pense que ça ça recommencera est
inéluctablement
c'est la raison pour laquelle moi je
considère qu'il faut sauver le front
républicain n'est pas le front
républicain
malsain de l'entre-deux tours le front
républicain c'est maintenant le front
républicain c'est de proposer aux
français une politique qui s'adresse aux
classes populaires qui n'entre pas dans
la logique destructrice du vote
rassemblement national qui ne favorise
pas à la montée des sentiments
xénophobes et qui ne fracture pas le
peuple français entre entre communautés
entre ethnies et c'est maintenant que ça
se joue certainement pas dans
l'entre-deux tours moi vous savez j'ai
vécu le 21 avril 2002 au nouvel
observateur je venais d'arriver je
venais d'être engagée il ya à peine
armand au nouvel observateur j'ai vécu
une scène qui m'a extrêmement frappé le
lendemain le 22 avril nous sommes dans
le bio
nous sommes plusieurs journalistes de la
base un bureau de laurent joffrin et
nous entendons le célèbre éditorialiste
et directeur délégué de l'ops jacques
julliard dire maintenant il faudra
toujours dire la vérité lui avait pris
d'une certaine façon la mesure de
l'événement j'avais cru sur le coup
qu'il en tirer la conclusion que cette
fois ci la gauche je devais vraiment
faire son examen de conscience et
notamment cessé de livrer le peuple
français au au front national au parti
du diable mais visiblement je m'étais
lourdement trompés puisque vingt ans
plus tard nous avons vingt ans plus tard
nous serons vingt ans plus tard lors de
la prochaine présidentielle et nous
sommes exactement dans la même
problématique qu'en 2002 je pense que
tout le monde devrait y réfléchir on a
vu à la fois sous emmanuel macron mais
avance ou françois hollande sous nicolas
sarkozy est même déjà sous jacques
chirac on voit des ministres et pas des
moindres sur les mêmes thématiques que
celles du rassemblement national ou
avant du front national soit disant
toujours pour mieux lutter contre le
front national ou rassemblement national
mais qui finissent au fond par dire
exactement la même chose et on accuse
ceux qui refusent de voter pour sa de
collusion avec l'extrême droite c'est
quand même un peu fort vous trouvez pas
christophe pour me di pompéo s'assurer
qu'au moins sur certaines déclarations
de certains ministres j'ai un peu de mal
personnellement si j'étais ministre je
vous ferai pas dire ça il est même à le
penser mais voilà c'était chacun envoyé
le problème c'est que le problème ou
l'instruction quand on fait un
gouvernement où il ya aussi bien des
hommes de droite que des hommes de
gauche parce qu'il à dire des gauches
aussi à des femmes de gauche de
gouvernement et des femmes des droites
et des hommes de droite on a des
libertés de parole des poids qui à mon
avis sortent du cadre dans lesquels
devaient sauver les choix qui est
affichée d'ailleurs vous là la ministre
du de la recherche moi je suis
universitaire quand on parle du salon
gauchiste à l'université ou quand on
voudrait imposer un modèle de pensée à
l'université c'est quelque chose qui moi
me choque profondément
les deux frères j en vois là c'est des
choses auxquelles avocate je tire pour
les bons
je suis pas tout seul on est beau comme
ça maintenant on peut pas empêcher un 1
mise de s'exprimer mais les thèses ou
les dires des différents ministres ne
vont pas le fût ce canal jusqu'à jusqu'à
marine le pen
on n'évoquait pas des pas de sortie que
ces deux clubs ya pas de parfum de
sortie raciste il ya pas moins vous
savez au jeu j'ai plus depuis tout à
l'heure et je me dis que on peut
toujours ce désir c'est pareil entre le
pen et mâcon c'est pareil et de toute
façon on peut dire ça on n'ira pas voter
au deuxième tour on reste que c'est soit
parce qu'on ne peut pas voter battront
en pensant toujours que mal le pen sera
pas élu comme lui je pense que l'arrière
pensent leurs arrières pensées allaient
dans le fond on est là c'est qu'on pense
toujours que ça n'arrivera pas moi je
suis un observateur de paris fonction
assemblée nationale de l'italie et en
italie ça devait pas réglé et pourtant
en italie on a élu salvini l'extrême
droite qui est rentré au gouvernement
voilà c'est ça la réalité c'est que si
on n'y prend pas garde
voilà et je dois vous dire rappelez-vous
salvini qu'est ce qu'il faisait il
empêcher les bateaux de migrants arrivés
son compte je suis d'accord avec toi
horonya quand tu parles de ça va mal
très dense à calais les plus de l'avoir
bien sûr mais on n'a jamais empêché des
bateaux d'arriver d'arrivée ritaline
charmant là donc c'est pas la même chose
donc pas banaliser et il faut pas se
dire ça n'arrivera jamais parce que ça
peut arriver si on ne prend pas garde
pablo pino il vient et ensuite en rien
tâche et oui en fait moi je n'ai à
bondir sur quelque chose que disait le
député de di pompéo tout à l'heure quand
il a parlé de la loi
la loi séparatisme il a commencé en fait
son analyse en disant voilà moi à
maubeuge la ville tout je suis où je
suis député il ya 35 % de la population
qui est en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
je sais ce que vous avez c'est le
chiffre que vous avez donné et tout de
suite après vous avez dit et donc du
coup c'est pour ça qu'il faut la loi
séparatisme mais en fait c'est
précisément cela dont les français ne
veulent plus et qui en fait là vous
cadenasser le débat c'est à dire que
effectivement vous partez d'une
hypothèse qui est une problématique
sociale et je ne sais pas par quel tour
de passe passe
vous arrivez à la question des musulmans
et c'était 5 et 7 e cette façon de
réfléchir
elle est systématique en ce moment c'est
à dire que vous avez il ya une
foultitude de problème il ya le govic
des primes sociaux etc étaient
systématiquement vous allez sur sur les
terres du front national sur le terrain
privilégié du front national et vous
dites à regarder en musique noire 41
voilà reparti du séparatisme à regarder
après 17 à nice et le dif est une espèce
de bouillabaisse avec une bouillabaisse
argumentaire honnêtement on a énormément
de mal à suivre
mais non mais c'est vrai c'est ce que
vous avez dit on a énormément de mal à
ce qu ils veulent et c'est pourquoi nous
et là on reparle zehnacker attendait
juste je finis je finis en une phrase
c'est là que nous c'est là que la gauche
en fait énormément de mal à reprendre la
main en fait sur le sur le sur le lido
en fait du débat public politique
français parce que parce qu'en fait du
le cadenasser et et venez vous faites et
c'est ça qui fait monter marine le pen
c'est exactement le type de raisonnement
vous avez du talent vous à leurs maîtres
ont profondément nui pour venir vous
feront vous vous trompez profondément
quand je parle quand je fais le lien
quand j'ai fait le lien et dans ma ville
je vois spacek quand je fais le lien
avec la pauvreté on a 35 % de notre
population qui vit sous le seuil de
pauvreté
vous allez dès lors que le chiffre
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que les populations entières qui sont en
désespérance qui sont des espérances qui
n'ont plus de vie sociale
s'ils ne vont plus au travail qui sont
chez eux et le seul le seul lien social
le seul lien social la seule chose qui
les guide la seule chose qui les
reconnaît c'est la mosquée et quand je
parle de séparatisme qui les lie et la
pauvreté c'est parce que pour sauver une
vie sociale et je parle pas et je parle
pas de population étrangère
moi je vous parle du population
française qui aujourd'hui se sont
convertis à l'islam et qui sont dans ces
paradis à l'ena réalité elle est là et
donc c'est assez le fait de cette
pauvreté qui fait aujourd'hui qu'on a
séparatisme dans ma ville
voilà un pizza signalement détendez vous
répondez la justice sociale et angers la
mosquée d'istres est parfaitement clair
tout mais c'est très clair venez voir un
peu au lieu de sebha sud de parler venez
voir un peu la réalité
moi j'ai 200 gamins chaque semaine qui
tout le week-end ne prennent pas de
bazire ils sont dans des écoles pour
apprendre à lire à la réalité elle est
là et je leur jette pas la pierre parce
qu'on n'a pas autre chose à proposer
et c'est un problème voilà je vais vous
dire ils sont je disais tout à l'heure
orange fait d'être musulman lassus
belles choses qu'on ait fait la plus
belle chose pour défiler aujourd'hui
c'est de dédoubler et de mettre des
classes à en 12 gamin parce que c'est
également là il faut leur donner la
possibilité de sortir de la fonction et
voilà c'est ça la solution il faut
instruire instruire instruire alors on
peut maintenant rapport prendre des
positions comme la vôtre en disant oh là
là mais c'est pas très bien et c'est lui
qui fait tout terrain du sco nationale
je vous dis il n'y a pas plus anti
fondation et que moi franchement alors
là et c'est pas une potion moi je suis
profondément gauche et je pense à ces
gamins parce que chez moi justement on
n'est plus des liens magnet gré on est
tous des enfants d'immigrés et on a tous
grandi ensemble et je vois tous ceux qui
ont fait des études qui ont tué à
l'époque où l'école était et est encore
là sociale est encore permis sont sortis
mais voilà je vais pas là-bas gamme je
vais pas d' amalgame
or je sais pourquoi je l'aurais de la
tâche est oui alors christophe moi je ne
dis pas que c'est exactement la même
chose
encore une fois évidemment que si le pen
demain est au pouvoir on n'ira même pas
cherché ce qui sur les bateaux ont pu
venir en france ensuite même si on n'a
pas laissé les bateaux à rester en
france on vous l'a coster d'italie
m'enfin bon puis quelques unes des
personnes qui était dessus bien sûr que
ce sera pire si
c'est le pen demain mais ça ça n'est pas
suffisant comme réponse aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui attendait véritablement autre
chose on ne peut pas juste se contenter
de ça et effectivement moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
marine le pen peut gagner parce que et
on le voit dans les débats que quand on
va à l'instant par exemple sur le
séparatisme ou sur sur les réfugiés ou
sur d'autres
en fait il y a comme on aurait
intériorisé le fait que les français
aujourd'hui
de toute façon sur ces questions là ne
peuvent plus entendre qu'une autre
politique est possible que réaffirmer
des valeurs humanistes est possible que
ce serait même la grandeur de la france
que de le faire et que ça pourrait même
être bon pour l'ensemble de la nation et
donc à force d'avoir cédé cdc décédé sur
ce terrain là au nom du fait que si on
n'était pas suffisamment réalistes sur
ces questions c'était le pen qui
progressaient eh bien on est en train de
l'installer au contraire au pouvoir
parce que à la fin qu'est ce qui
différencie suffisamment les deux
politiques qui sont années si ce n'est
des question de curseur et non plus des
questions de nature donc moi je suis
extrêmement inquiet ça fait longtemps
que je pense
il peut être en étant minoritaire dans
dans ce qu'était ce camp dont va dire
gauche réformiste si on peut aussi ses
mots ont encore un sens parce que je
pense qu'ils n'ont plus beaucoup mais
enfin de dire que sur ces questions là
il fallait au contraire relevé le gant
qu'il fallait réaffirmer nos valeurs
qu'il fallait et sous le quinquennat
précédent ça n'a pas été fait non plus
au moment où merkel en une phrase dit on
va y arriver
pour accueillir un million de personnes
nous et je le sais puisque j'ai témoin à
charge et notamment pour les ministres
du logement mettre en place ces
politiques d'accueil et des migrantes on
faisait à bas bruit en disant voilà il
ne faut surtout pas dire aux français ce
qu'on fait mais bien sûr qu'il faut dire
aux français ce qu'on fait parce que
d'ailleurs sur le terrain quand on le
faisait et christophe sûr que tu le sais
quand on ouvre un centre pour accueillir
des gens et bien au départ et de la
réticence puis au final après ça se
passe bien ça se passe bien c'est même
les gens qui souvent 10 mais pourquoi
pas plus loin donc la responsabilité du
politique c'est ça la responsabilité du
politique c'est d'affirmer des valeurs
c'est de poser des mots ces 2 c'est un
moment de faire preuve de courage et moi
ce que je reproche aujourd'hui
profondément à ceux qui sont au pouvoir
et ce que je reprochais déjà assez
largement à ceux qui les ont précédés
c'est ça c'est finalement de se dire de
toute façon on ne peut plus rien changer
ou pas suffisamment donc il faut éviter
le moindre mal et sur la question du
séparatisme c'est la même chose
oui à maubeuge chez toi c'est très
compliqué oui dans un certain nombre de
quartiers c'est très compliqué et bien
alors il faut vraiment se donner les
moyens de faire changer les choses et
pas simplement aller fric et anne ou
telle association
il faut faire en sorte que en terme de
mixité dans les écoles en terme de
mixité sociale et les réponses à la
hauteur des enjeux
ça fait 20 ans qu'on n'a pas mis des
sommes conséquentes sur la table sur ces
questions ça fait c'était borloo s'était
l'anru donc je veux dire c'est quoi la
france aujourd'hui on n'est plus capable
on connaît les problèmes dont on
n'aurait plus les moyens de
véritablement des politiques
structurantes et donc on va gérer
voilà en bout de course vraiment les
plus grosses disciples les plus grosses
difficultés essayer d'éviter un vraiment
les mots les plus terribles ces salles
ambitions politiques qu'on propose aux
français
et bien moi je suis pas étonné que
finalement les jours d'élection il
décide de rester chez eux donc c'est
vraiment là dessus qu'il va falloir se
poser un peu
si on veut que ça bouge parce que sinon
non je crois je présente à moi je crois
que marine le pen cette fois ci arrivera
parce que il n'y a plus suffisamment de
différences c'est vraiment des histoires
de curseur et si c'est que ça et bien
les gens laisseront faire en 2002
jacques chirac avait fait moins de 20%
des voix au premier tour
il a été élu avec 80 2% face à jean
marie le pen et manuellement maquereau
en 2017 il a fait 24 % au premier tour
et
et c'est 24% se sont transformés en 66 %
au 2e tour face à marine le pen s'est
massé magique marine le pen ça multiplie
les voir c'est extraordinaire mais à
chaque fois aussi bien jacques chirac en
2002 qui emmanuel macron en 2017
on pensait qu'ils étaient élus sur leurs
programmes sur leur bonne tête et et
n'ont absolument rien changé ensuite
c'est à dire que souviens pas que
jacques chirac que ce soit ouvert son
gouvernement à aa des ministres de
gauche par exemple apparaître tout dans
les 82 % il y avait beaucoup d'électeurs
de gauche ni que emmanuel macron effet
particulièrement d'efforts dans ce
domaine avec ses 66 %
est-ce qu'il ya pas une erreur
aujourd'hui elle a à la fois une
amulette magique on est face à marine le
pen
tapis rouge et en même temps une erreur
on croit qu'on a été élu alors qu'en
fait non elle a été éliminée au de
l'ancien nom oui alors effectivement
effectivement marine le pen a fait un
score plus important que son père face à
emmanuel macron au premier toit en 2017
ça n'a pas empêché manuel mâcon de fêter
sa victoire prochaine dès le premier
tour
comme on s'en souvient à la rotonde ski
ski ce qui est certain c'est que aucun
d'eux aucun des deux ne me ni jacques
chirac ni emmanuel macron maman on en
tirer les conclusions
non effectivement ouvert leur pris la
mesure de l'événement ne se sont placés
dans une logique transpartisane c'est la
raison pour laquelle je suis aussi
inquiète pour la suite en 2022 parce que
je me souviens de certaines naïveté qui
avait été prononcée en 2010 c'est dans
l'antre de tour quand on nous sommés
d'aller voter pour emmanuel macron et je
me souviens notamment d'un bain d'un
grand thomas économiste réputé
mondialement pour le pour lequel
d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup d'estimé thomas
piketty mais je l'entends fin avril 2017
je l'entends encore dans une interview
qu'il fallait voter massivement pour
emmanuel macron l'ensevelir sous les
bulletins de vote pour qu'ils
comprennent que ce n'était pas son
programme qui était élu et que donc il
en tire toutes les conclusions et
malheureusement je pense que dans dans
la psyché des gens de gauche rien a
tellement changé en termes de naïveté et
que ce genre et que nous allons vivre
encore ce genre de moments dans la vie
qui vient vous le pensez aussi à pablo
pino vie veille
vivien oui oui d'autant plus que moi moi
j'avais écrit une tribune dans
libération appelant à voter mené le
maquereau pour le au deuxième tour
honnêtement parfois je relis cette
tribune et j'ai mal au ventre veut dire
un jeu les bras m'en tombent
rien de ce que j'avais rien de ce que
j'appelais de mes voeux ni la défense de
la république ni la défense de la
démocratie
nahla lieux et les domaines des trucs tu
sais si marine le pen arrive au pouvoir
s'est aucunement comparable parce
qu'elle elle elle sera xénophobe
d'assumer et force est de constater que
c'est plutôt macron aujourd'hui kim à
une belgique politique xénophobe comme
disent aurélien kong l'autiste quand
j'entends certains ce que certains
députés ont dit de la république en
marche sur les gilet jaune en disant
qu'ils étaient manipulés par moscou et
par cousine je me demande qui est en
plus petits c'est marine le pen c'est
emmanuel macron nostalgie de grands noms
de notre histoire dont nous avons honte
et qui ne devrait une force et qu'elle
demande est parfois étonné réparation
moi je pensais que ça s'était marine le
pen en fait qu'à une si elle prenait le
pouvoir qu'elle est faire ça quand jean
quand je vois ce que fait macron qui
veut c'est des blagues et en a en fait
je veux dire que j'ai tout faux dans la
tribune que j'avais rédigé donc qu'en
haute je t'entends dire je comparais de
thomas piketty peut-être que thomas
piketty aussi s'est dit bon match même
si je me suis trompé on a droit de se
tromper on à droite d'imaginer quelque
chose à un instant t
et puis 3 4 en cinq ans après
voir voir qu'on a les phares et non ce
que je veux ce que je veux dire aussi
c'est qu'il va falloir que l'on se
remette collectivement mais ça ça marche
pour emmanuel macron et pour la gauche à
faire de la politique parce qu'en fait
c'est ça le problème à mon avis c'est ça
dont manque le débat public aujourd'hui
c'est de faire de la politique
emmanuel macron il a eu des petites
idées n'était pas si mauvaise que ça le
grand débat national ce n'était pas une
si mauvaise idée que ça la convention
pour le climat s'était pas non plus une
cible à visiter que ça je suis propre
site et des occasions en fait de
vraiment faire de la politique
faire un débat national et avec tt
président était prêt dès vraie
confrontation du vrai conflit politique
le seul point c'est qu'il a tout pris a
tout jeté à la poubelle donc c'est le
constat est absolument monstrueux mais
si on arrive aujourd'hui en france on a
encore un an pour faire ça à recréer
cette envie collective
alors qu'en france 2 politique je pense
qu'on peut réussir à éviter le duo marie
le pen néanmoins on s'en souvient plus
aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron a bénéficié d'un
alignement de planètes extraordinaires
en 2017
quand il crée en marchant en avril il a
mathématiquement vous êtes mathématicien
christophe di pompéo il a mathématiques
n'ont aucune chance de l'emporter
normalement il va avoir en face de lui
alain juppé qui va lui prendre les voix
du centre droit il va avoir françois
hollande qui va lui prendre une partie
des voix du centre gauche et il va avoir
françois béraud qui va lui prendre les
voix du centre il n'a aucune chance
d'être au deuxième tour
et c'est là où il ya un alignement de
planètes formidable parce qu'au lieu de
la jupe et ça va être françois fillon
une droite beaucoup plus dure beaucoup
plus libérales au lieu de françois
hollande ça va être benoît hamon la
frange la plus à gauche du parti
socialiste
et en plus françois bayroux voyant qui
n'a rien à gagner dans l'histoire va
renoncer à se présenter est là
mathématiquement il ne peut plus perdre
mais rien ne dit que ça va se passer
aussi magiquement la prochaine fois a
priori s'il n'y a à gogo un candidat de
centre gauche
et s'il ya à droite un candidat de
centre-droit rien
dit que mariner que emmanuel macron sera
au deuxième tour me dit tout peut
arriver
moi je me souviens quand j'ai rejoint
2016 les intentions de vote pour lui
était à 10%
jamais je n'aurais pensé à moi ce moment
là emmanuel macron semé quelques mois
plus tard ils ont accueilli effet moins
quelques mois plus tard encore je serai
députés vraiment il ya la ménude planète
elle le la chance qui a souri à l'est du
lac rond tout le monde son parcours pour
devenir président et c'est pour ça que
quand on dit deuxième tour macron le pen
tout peut arriver
moi je pense tout peut arriver mais
faut-il encore faire de la politique je
reprends ce que disait tout à l'heure
faut-il encore faire de la politique et
pour faire de la politique je pense
qu'il faut arrêter de sortir il faut
arrêter de la caricature moi quand je
vous entends parler vraiment on est dans
la caricature de l'extrême où tout est
mauvais tu t'es comble au tout et ceci
tout est ce que ça va vraiment faire de
la politique je pense ce n'est pas
critiquer systématiquement mais celle ci
est proposé quelque chose et pour ce cru
et c'est là où la gauche fn aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de proposition il
n'y a pas de construction
et quand je vous entends pablo moi je me
dis mais attendez s'il veut faire de la
politique qu'ils proposent c'est ça la
politique s'est proposé pour donner
envie de voter c'est pas dire qu'il
n'est pas il n'est pas bien il
antirépublicain il est xénophobe
je suis désolé maquereau ou xénophobe
moi je veux bien entendre beaucoup mais
ça c'est 100 saas et de bêtise c'est une
bêtise on ne pas dire une chose comme
cela madoff
ça n'a pas de sens de dire ça n'a pas de
sens de dire alors sortez de la
caricature fait de la politique et
proposer des choses que les gens aient
envie de voter pour vous il est la
preuve de la gauche c'est qu'on appelle
donne pas envie d'allumer enduit moi
j'ai quitté la gauche pourquoi tant
joignez le débat à l'assemblée nationale
avec les fondeurs etc je n'ai pas envie
quand j'ai vu le débat sur la déchéance
de nationalité
j'ai plus envie j'avais plus envie et
donc pour qu'on vote pour les gens il
faut donner envie et la gauche
aujourd'hui le fait pas envie parce
qu'elle est dans la caricature
elle n'est pas par sa proposition elle
est toujours dans un une opposition à
outrance qui n'a pas de sens
il y attacher emmanuel macron il faisait
plutôt envie en 2010 est surtout quand
on le comparer aux autres candidats
est ce qu'il fera suffisamment envie en
2023 et
pour être ne serait ce qu'au deuxième
tour 1022 à redon alors évidemment
maintenant il ya un quinquennat entre
les deux seins donc tous les espoirs
qu'avaient puis mettre les uns ou les
autres pour différentes raisons
d'ailleurs bon l'épreuve du pouvoir
voilà révélera et moi ce que je enfin on
verra ce qu'il en reste après après
après l'épreuve du pouvoir moi je crois
qu'il n'en restera malheureusement que
peu de chose qu'à par certaines
catégories de la population pour qui
globalement la vie n'est pas trop
difficile et qui s'inquiètent de menaces
et si vous la et se disent que macron
semble essayer d'y répondre
bon ces gens-là continueront peut-être
de voter pour lui je ne pense pas que ce
soit suffisant donc en revanche qui est
vrai c'est que aujourd'hui
enfin moi je crois pas qu'en politique
tous soient écrits vous venez d'en faire
la démonstration en évoquant 2017 et
après par contre vous avez dit frédéric
taddeï si un candidat de centre-droit ya
candidat de centre-gauche
je pense que ça ne fonctionne pas comme
ça que ce qui manque aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement tant sur le plan collectif
que sur le plan aussi de celui qui se
lancera dans la cinquième dans la course
à la présidentielle parce que ce soit 5
ème république ça fonctionne comme ça
personnellement je le regrette et je
pense qu'une grande partie de nos maux
viennent de cela mais pour l'instant que
ce soit sur le plan de la dynamique
collective et de projets ou sur le
rapport aux français pour un candidat ou
une candidate
il n'y a pas ce qu'il faut pour empêcher
emmanuel macron d'être au deuxième tour
mais que ça peut arriver à tout moment
et vous savez mon à la période où on
mais voilà je je je vois bien comment se
comportent les uns les autres
ce service d'à-côté écologistes de
l'autre jean luc mélenchon de l'autre
malheureusement c'est vrai que là je
retrouve une fin d un des grands travers
de la gauche politique française à
savoir se croire perpétuellement en
congrès plutôt que d'essayer de parler
aux français et d'emporter une élection
et penser que le plus important est donc
effectivement surtout de faire attention
à la concurrence de ces deux de ses
alliés et je ne vois pas de
2 je ne vois pas de parti de dynamique
de collectifs qui soit à la hauteur des
enjeux et qui sont incapables de
finalement se dire bon le front national
arrive comment comment on fait pour
éviter cela et donc ça ça m'inquiète et
je crois que dans la période où on va
entrer c'est plus près les cours les
caractères les les tempéraments qu'il va
falloir rechercher voilà je pense quand
on a besoin véritablement de gens qui
sont capables d'être intransigeant sur
leurs valeurs qui sont capables d'être
plus fidèles à leurs valeurs qu alors
partie callen groupe parlementaire kkk
leur famille politique d'origine et que
si cette france humaniste arrive à
trouver des endroits pour se rencontrer
à trouver un leader uni 2 pour porter
ses couleurs en 2022 emmanuel macron ne
sera pas au second tour mais c'est plus
facile à dire qu'à faire
et c'est vrai que si on regarde
simplement ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui sur
le papier on ne voit pas du tout cela
arriver mais on ne voyait pas non plus
emmanuel macron arrivé en 2007 alors
dernière question il reste très peu de
temps
aude lancelin 2022 vous n'êtes pas allés
voter
pour emmanuel macron imaginons que
marine le pen est élue tant pis pas
boivent pas de problème c'est blanc
bonnet et bonnet blanc bien sûr que si
un gros problème démocratique mais bon
voilà au bout d'un moment ce processus
malsain doit aller à son terme et nous
nous nous le combattrons de toutes nos
forces nous serons dans la rue comme
nous le sont comme nous le sommes
régulièrement depuis deux ans déjà que
voulez vous on ne peut pas voter pour
pour éteindre un incendie on ne peut pas
continuer à voter pour l'incendiaire
l'incendiaire c'est le pouvoir donné au
cac 40 quasi directement via un fondé de
pouvoir du capital
on peut pas continuer comme ça donc non
une fois de plus je ne voterai
évidemment pas emmanuel macron si ce cas
de figure se présentait mais je ne pense
pas qu'il se présentera je ne pense pas
qu emmanuel macron sera au second tour
si vous voulez tout savoir voulais juste
utiliser mon dernier tour de parole pour
répondre à quelque chose que qui a dit
monsieur le député qui est tout à
l'heure à qui est quand même assez
scandaleux vous vous reprocher aux gens
comme vous dit d'aller à la mosquée
parce qu'ils n'ont ils n'ont rien
d'autre à faire dans des zones détruites
et et vous vous semblez être dans
l'empathie par rapport à ces gens là
mais quand on sait ce que le quinquennat
des bagnoles maquereau a fait pour
détruire le lien social pour retirer dès
le premièr été les appels aux étudiants
maintenant on s'en prend aux aux
allocations chômage
entre-temps mam a rasé les ronds points
pour éviter les gens de retrouver la
fraternité de se rencontrer à nouveau
tout ce que vous avez fait viser à
rompre ce lien social qui vous dérange
finalement donc jeu et tout ça pour en
arriver à la conclusion que oui les
mosquées se remplissent mais là on a
beau résumé de l'imposture moral que
représente ce quinquennat
ce sera le mot de la fin puisque
l'émission est terminée
merci tous les quatre d'avoir participé
à ce débat merci de nous avoir suivis et
rendez vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coups